this is a production of cornell
university
it's going to be an interesting ride
today uh
being 35 plus years at cornell and so
the title is is it just grass well maybe
it was working
okay now it's not all right we'll go
this way we were having that work or
maybe it's a little more and that's what
i want to i think that's my take home
message when i look at
turf and turf grass areas i see them
from a slightly different perspective
than maybe you might and so that's the
that's what i want to share today and
i'm not talking about this kind of grass
you know it was always the
the laughter in my family or i meet
somebody well what do you do i said well
i work with grass and so the snicker is
is this kind of grass i said no that's
not even a grass but
but at least it's more like this kind of
grass the deal with golf courses and
lawns and sod farms and athletic fields
and commercial grounds like campuses
like this
airport strips roadsides i mean anything
that's using grass species that are
routinely mowed
for all kinds of reasons and all kinds
of functions
and so what i'd like to go over today
are some of the kind of functions that
we use turf grasses and land and in
landscapes as well as part of landscapes
and so there's an aesthetic component a
financial component a recreational
component and the last one that i'll
actually show a bunch of data on is
ecosystem function uh services for
turf grass and landscapes
and so we can't deny that you have these
beautiful grassy
vistas that in this case on eastern long
island the golf course or our beautiful
sports field well maybe thus is not that
beautiful
i got this picture i'm there how do you
play soccer on that field you know
or you have a little sneak attack over
and those shrubs to the bottom left
there it's
and that would be an interesting one to
maintain as well as kind of play on that
would be a one to nothing kind of
facility but more like a sports field
like this like yankee stadium
that frank's not here today but frank
has been very instrumental in working
with yankee stadium over the years but
i'm from pittsburgh so the pnc park for
the pittsburgh pirates at least his team
have made the playoffs the last two
years unlike the yankees
yeah i know to kind of rub it in just a
little bit a little bit but a lot of
times we think about golf and sports
turf is is like the big thing of turf
and they are the visible things they're
on television you know articles written
about them and whatever but there are a
lot of
kind of other uses uh that we might see
so you can see grass is used at art form
and we know
marchand sheebly has done a lot of kind
of sod related projects for from an art
perspective and her students have done
some really cool things with grasses
but a lot of times we think more of the
traditional version of a landscape
that that we see in in suburban areas
where you have a green carpet adding to
the value of this landscape
that we see there and then so one it may
be a visual thing you may enjoy it um
but also there are some financial
implications and
um there have been a number of surveys
looking at the economic value of
landscapes uh to
to the property value itself and so
landscapes can add as much as seven to
fifteen percent to the to the value of a
home uh so poor landscape would uh would
get you less if you were trying to to
sell that property and so clemson did a
study of showing that homes with
excellent landscapes you can expect to
sell price to be six to seven percent
higher than
an equivalent good landscape and while
improving your landscape from average to
good you could even see a result of four
to five percent so there is an economic
value to
uh the the even though there is a visual
effect to the to these kind of
landscapes
now you may not have known so i'm going
to throw some facts out how large the
use of turf grasses are say in the us
and so a study done in 2005 estimated
there are over 30 million acres of
maintained turf in new york
in in the united states
and if we come a little bit closer to
home new york state has 30 million
land acres now if we added all the water
in whatever new york state is bigger
than but new york state has 30 million
land acres so all the turfis in the
united states is big of the land area of
new york state within new york state
they're over 3.4 million acres of turf
grass
accounting for from 2003 figures five
billion dollars per year in maintenance
costs
mostly on residential properties that's
about 70 percent of the land area uh
about 43 000 workers with an annual
payroll of at least 500 million dollars
done by the new york state ag statistics
service not an industry group as some
people always like to point out when you
have surveys done while you're just
inflating these figures this was done by
the new york state act statistics
service
but there are a lot of recreational
things if we get away from the beauty
the uh financial value there aren't too
many surfaces natural surfaces that we
have that you can recreate on constantly
and have it be left and frank we're here
his daughter's actually in this picture
that's why one of the reasons i like to
to use it
and it's from trumansburg too that's
some of our fields there
um so we look at this there really
aren't other natural surfaces that can
take
constant wear and traffic soil
compaction can be mowed closely those
golf course settings a putting green can
be as low as a tenth of an inch
harvested every day there aren't too
many agricultural systems we harvest
that low and that frequently and
hopefully something will grow
as part of that
but we do have some imposters
to this and and one of them we have an
example across the street this greenish
fakus that i'd like to call
is we have a synthetic turf across the
street and this was taken two weeks ago
they're out there irrigating the
synthetic turf across the street you
know it's kind of very ironic that you
would think
in late october we're out irrigating
well it's done to control the speed of
that surface for the ball roll that the
field hockey players the women's field
hockey field
so even with artificial surfaces you do
need to do some kind of maintenance
including irrigation to some degree but
what i'd really like to cover today is
to talk about
the ecosystem services you could get
from turf grasses and other
suburban landscapes
in that context
and so
there is this however if you're trying
to talk about positives having ecosystem
services are there negatives related to
these kind of land uses and so
uh there has been shown and i'm not
going to show data but there's been a
number of studies shown that uh water
quality in suburban areas can be
compromised and it's usually the two
things that are compromised is
phosphorus levels
tend to be high and if we were gonna
compare to uh an agricultural setting
those phosphorus levels may be higher in
surface waters than in agricultural
areas nitrogen levels are actually lower
and i'll show some data probably the
reason for that
and are also pesticides that are that
are used in landscapes in these suburban
areas that have compromised water
quality
so from that there have been
restrictions at both state and local
levels
either restricting the type and amount
and season of application for pesticides
and fertilizers mostly fertilizers and
banning pesticides if you
new york state has a
ban on school ground pesticide use
unless there are some very limited ones
you're able to use or you can get an
emergency exception to it and jenny
gowniff has been doing a lot of work
with that because many of the problems
we have on school grounds are weed
related and trying to manage weeds
without the traditional herbicide
approach becomes quite quite difficult
so that's been one of the parts of this
as we have seen regulations put in and
those of us i mean i work in the
political end and restrictions are made
by politicians not by scientists
and quite often i think if they really
understood
uh the science behind what they're
trying to regulate they might have done
something differently so as an example
new york state has a
ban on applying phosphorus to turf areas
uh except for a couple couple ways one
if you're establishing a turf area you
can put it down
or you or you take a soil test and
there's a need for it so those are the
kind of two exceptions to it the problem
is the first one
is and i'll we will show you data that
if you were going to be putting
phosphorus down the time establishment
you have very little plants there to
hold on to that those nutrients nitrogen
and phosphorus and runoff and leaching
can be pretty significant a matter of
fact that's the worst time when we look
at all the studies done on the fader
fertilizers and turf that's the worst
time environmentally so the regulator
should have said do a soil test to see
if you need phosphorus and establishment
and even that be careful what you're
putting down but they just gave a
blanket exception because there was a
law passed in minnesota there was one in
wisconsin so new york legislators were
smart enough just to grab those and
probably not
take the advice of people like me who
wrote to them and asked them to consider
not putting that in there
we do need phosphorus and establishment
because the soil is already adequate and
it doesn't really do you very much good
and then so from that um are there
positives ecosystem wise uh i wouldn't
say to counteract but what are the
benefits we might see ecosystem function
benefits
and we need to i think we need to always
evaluate that in a in a landscape scale
setting
so this is this is one thing that epa
put up several years ago make sure you
keep your fertilizer on your lawn and i
think that's a great idea
and if you kind of go down there there
is some stuff that talks about how to
manage turf and we've i've done a lot of
research over the years and most of it
i'm not going to be
showing today that are used to try to
help improve
the management of turf to minimize
environmental impact and we've spent a
lot of time and effort trying to do that
but what i want to cover today is kind
of three parts of ecosystem services
that that we've had graduate students
and i'm mostly giving my own graduate
students data today
um
at looking at what you could from uh
from a turf landscape
uh get what benefits you might get and
one large one we've we have found and
other people who've been studying this
is that storm water amounts the runoff
amounts can be significantly lower in a
turf grass area and they can in other
types of landscapes but it's really
based on the landscape type and the
plant density and the some degree age of
that site
and the second one has to deal with soil
phosphorus and phosphorus runoff and you
might say what is what kind of ecosystem
services
uh is benefit from that and i'll tell
you later because that is one of the
sections and the last one will talk
about carbonate and nitrogen
sequestration which is a big thing these
days in in most ecosystems
and what do we know about turf and that
in that context
so the stormwater one and runoff
said
to talk about in relationship to to
loading rates based on landscape type
and plant density issues
and
i've been fortunate over the years
to have a number of great grad students
zach easton was did a master's and a phd
so this was his master's work he's
currently done at vpi and i just saw
that he won the outstanding assistant
professor in the college of engineering
so i didn't know i was training
engineers but
but zach went on to do very many great
things he was here as a postdoc
in biological environmental engineering
for a number of years and it took a
faculty position down there
it was a turf guy you know it's it's
amazing to see where some of your grad
students go
so what did he determine in his masters
and this is a slide showing plant
density on the bottom shoot density and
on the left you have the amount of
runoff and on the right is the
infiltration rate of that soil so as you
double the shoots going from 5 to 10
shoots per centimeter
you cut the amount of runoff by two
thirds
and the reason you do that is the
infiltration rate doubled over that
period of time and so this kind of tells
us several things if for some reason you
lose plant density or don't have a very
dense surface to begin with runoff can
be a major issue so this was doing this
was done during an establishment phase
the first three months
of when these plots were put in this
this graph was put together so this
helps explain why i have this concern
over when you're putting down fertilizer
and there's no plants there what do you
think is going to happen well the chance
for runoff can be quite significant one
the volume of runoff erosion and also
what might be in that runoff water
um so sites with low density including
established are
really have been shown in this study and
a number of other studies pose the
greatest risk to runoff once it's
established
as we'll see there isn't as much
difference
depending on the landscapes there long
as you can maintain density
so zach went on to do
a landscape scale and this is what
started to get him into the engineering
part environmental engineering
looking at landscape types in a suburban
area and the amount of runoff and its
effect on a perennial stream going
through there so i had two phd students
working with zach easton's ph.d and then
mark slavins
after that with looking at a slightly
different study
so zach's work was done um in the
northeast section of ithaca going from
convenient care on warren road
to
kendall on trip hammer that subdivision
in that area and that's what this this
illustration shows
and the upper this is the watershed that
that stream is affected by and the
watershed the head part of that
watershed is actually the orthology lab
and a lot of wooded areas up there and
so if we kind of look here
this is basically his study area down
but this perennial stream flows through
there and he had a gauge here kind of
looking at the inflow
from the area above and then the stream
gage below that measured what happened
during that area of suburbanization so
if you've ever driven through that it's
a it's a typical subdivision homes built
in the 50s 60s and 70s for the most part
it's a perennial stream and so he looked
at
at basically
three different landscape types and
there were three replicas in this study
so let me go back
uh he had the upper part of this
watershed the numbers will be one kind
of the mid part of this watershed two
and the ones with three behind it are
the lower part so this is higher
elevation lower elevation and there's a
big difference in that watershed
the location that watershed what might
happen with that so we looked at three
different types of residential
landscapes suburban landscape a high
maintenance lawn convenient care kendall
all commercially maintained we didn't
have any control over what they were
doing but we knew what they put on it
wasn't something we defined matter of
fact we probably
knowing after we did soil tests the
soils levels were adequate in phosphorus
they still put phosphorus on but we
didn't want to these are so we just want
to look at real landscapes these are
real sites not not research typical
research plots
he had low maintenance areas that were
primarily grasses mostly mode one of
them was not mood at all and the other
was comparing a suburban wooded area a
deciduous tree area and looking at at
runoff and what was in that runoff on
this site so zach had this was a
three-year study so this kind of shows
the three different areas a high
maintained turf runoff collecting area
the low maintenance area and a wooded
area primarily with deciduous trees with
the litter drop from those trees
anytime there was an event
a runoff end greater than a tenth of a
millimeter they were collected and on
some of the plots there were 127 runoff
events in three years and he measured
dissolve react to phosphorus nitrate
ammonium and then be able to calculate
mass loss knowing the volumes of of
those areas
and so the i just wanted to show this is
a summary mostly to tell you about
season and two things but first is
the amount of runoff in the first two
years in the highly maintained turf site
compared to the wooded and low
maintenance area were significantly less
a third on this area
compared to this low maintenance turf
and about
two times less with the
uh the high maintenance turf area
compared to the wooded area and the
reason is is that type of dense plant
vegetation
a tremendous amount of surface rooting
and root activity earthworm activity
high infiltration rates runoff is
significantly less now if i were a storm
water management person and i didn't put
labels on this and you showed me these
things it said well what landscape would
you want to reduce runoff in stormwater
management you definitely would want
something like that so this is a benefit
that we don't always think about
in these landscapes but it's a it's a
it's a very significant landscape effect
this is the creek that runs a little bit
to the south of
uh
it goes through kendall yeah it crosses
yep
it's a small stream it's a perennial
stream
and uh very flashy which it reflects
runoff so if you get a little bit of
precipitation it'll be runoff and that's
so that stream is a very good stream to
study runoff because it does
it does quickly show
what can happen in that stream yeah it's
not a very big one it was an interesting
place though
okay this is a very busy table so i'm
going to try to
kind of walk you through it again we had
these three zones within that watershed
the threes were the lower end the ones
as we will see had the greatest amount
of runoff the most events runoff events
and the and the amount of runoff
occurring on this is an average amount
in each one of these runoff events this
middle section and then the and then
again on the upper end had the lowest
amount
of runoff events and the amount of
runoff occurring
so i highlighted the the ones that were
significantly different
so in runoff we had dissolved reactive
phosphorus either the concentration on
average this is the average
concentration coming out of those
those individual events and then the
total load of phosphorus coming from
that
so we could see in this lower part of
the watershed where there was the
greatest amount of significant amounts
of runoff we could see the fertilized
turf areas compared to the unfertilized
or forested area i really want to call
it a wooded area
we're significantly higher
and the total total phosphorus
concentration uh was also higher and the
load was just significantly higher than
than than only one of the two
if we look at the middle and upper parts
where the amount of runoff was
significantly less than those two areas
both in amount and on
and the number of events
we could see that
we could see less phosphorus runoff
in the the load of phosphorus runoff in
that area or at least it's relatively
equal in the upper end
the dissolved phosphorus ones we could
see there were no difference between
these landscapes or if there was in one
case it was slightly higher but the high
highly maintained turf was actually
less than that case
and what zack has
has concluded in this case that if we
kind of look at these
sites with low to moderate potential for
runoff and a watershed like that is
actually
a very uh
this is a very good kind of watershed to
study that uh high maintenance lawns had
the same or lower amount of dissolved
phosphorus total phosphorus runoff
compared to the unfertilized turf areas
or the wooded sites but the roof but the
issue was however when you get in these
high potential for runoff sites
we did see with the high maintenance
lawn there was an increase in the
loading rate of dissolved phosphorus
likely from fertilizing
but there was a quarter of them on the
particulate phosphorus loss because we
also measured in the sediment that came
off of those plots
so there was a reduction in that again
that reflects back the high density
area that increa that increases
infiltration rate
the amount of particulate or erosion was
significantly less
and then the same amount of total
phosphorus in the runoff compared
unfertilized and low maintenance areas
and wooded sites total p being slightly
different than the dissolved pea usually
dissolved phosphorus does relate back to
fertilization in many cases
so what happened in that stream over
this study it was kind of an interesting
thing you might think
that suburbanization is likely going to
do something it was shown that
suburbanization in that suburban part of
the water said that the outflow
uh the stream had the same level of
nitrates had higher ammonium levels
likely from the fertilization that was
occurring
uh more dissolved
phosphorus
during storm water storm events not
during kind of base flow of that stream
and higher particulate loss uh quote
erosion than the undeveloped section of
that watershed
so it is interesting to show that as as
as we kind of showed in the introduction
to this that you can see
suburban areas being a a source of
phosphorus uh and fertilized lawns
if you have a lard of that watershed
that's in in
in a higher risk are more likely to have
an impact if you have areas with really
moderate to to minimal runoff losses the
landscape itself has very little to do
with what
what might be coming off that area
okay
so the second student to kind of
followed on this was was
was mark slavin's uh he was looking at a
little different version of landscape
types
and runoff and actually unleashing uh
and
and and now mark is a vice president of
environmental affairs with with the
scots company and has been actually very
good at supporting us it's nice to have
somebody in these companies when you
need seed and fertilizer and they're
making some significant contributions to
some projects we've had
we'd like to get some research money on
them too but it's nice to actually get
some product too
so his objective in his his phd work was
trying to determine the relationship
between lawn density and composition
on nutrient and pesticide loading
and he had basically four
kind of grass type perennial grass type
lawn treatments
and four
uh
sometimes perennial but non-typical kind
of grass lawn types and so we had one
with kentucky bluegrass
and
what we did is basically had four of
these that were initially soldered with
kentucky bluegrass so you had nice plant
density to start with
one that after that point all it did
would get what was to get mowed one that
we added fertilizer to
fertilizers and pesticides fertilized
pesticides and irrigation so going from
intensity of minimal maintenance other
the mowing to the most intense one where
we're adding even irrigation into it
and so basically we put on as it turns
out a program very similar to what scots
would sell you in a four-step program
for your lawn so there were four
applications with fertilizer and these
were the pesticides were in those to
control
broadleaf weeds broadleaf weeds and
insect and annual grassy weeds
so that would be something if you went
to went down and bought a typical
program this is what you might see
for a typical lawn
high maintenance line
so the other set of treatments involved
having
either directly having other kinds of
weedy material in there
smooth crabgrass and smooth crabgrass
with half turf so we plugged out half of
this area and i say we i didn't do that
but mark and my technician jeff and
helpers did that
so that you had a 50 at least initially
50 turf grass 15 annual grass
and the annual ones these were just
seeded each year to to try to keep those
in there
a broadleaf wheatie one that had very
high broadleaf had high very high
density in it and then one again we
plugged in uh
kentucky bluegrass sod initially at one
one to one weed broadleaf weed to
um to grass and there were four
replicates of of these treatments
okay
so we wanted to do a typical kind of
residential suburban con
type installation so the bulldozer was
brought in removed all the soil brought
back
and and compacted with equipment like
this to simulate what you do when you
build a a new site and the top soil was
put back on it
we did two sets of types of collections
in this study
we had these
two by three foot
lysometers pushed in the ground pulled
out
a bottom pvc bottom put on and a drain
line coming out of those so all the
water that would be infiltrating through
the soil and leaching out would would be
collected those are on the upper surface
of these
of these plots
and at this the slope is about a nine to
twelve percent slope uh
we've put a
a gutter collecting system so that all
runoff events coming from those areas so
you can see this is
crab grass not very much there the the
perennial broadleaf weed area and then
the straight kentucky bluegrass next to
it this is what they look like at
establishing
so what did we find in from a leaching
perspective
we found that there were this is the
volume of of leaching occurring over a
two year period uh that except for one
kind of plot uh most of them had a
similar amount
uh over that period of time there were
about 1100 millimeters of of
precipitation
and we can see that we're seeing about
some of these ones about a third of what
the precipitation end up leaching
through the soil which is actually a
pretty high amount
as compared to some other studies
and so what did things like nitrate look
like concentration and a lot of times
and so this is the nitrate mass loss
over time
and if we kind of look up here this this
highest one up here
okay it's the one with one dash mark
made these slides i didn't i would have
probably made a little bit different
version so it may be a little bit easier
to read we can see and this is the these
are approximately
samples taken monthly bulk together
monthly and then been analyzed
we can see that the worst one in this
case happened to be the one that is at
least comparing the turf ones the one
that was turf with nothing else added to
it
and as we can see the one with the
highest
kind of after that tends to be the the
turf with fertilizer and a little bit
less with the other ones then after this
kind of establishment even though these
were sought after this establishment
year there were a couple peaks later on
and and it reflected
sometimes some treatment was slightly
higher than the others but there was
always a baseline amount coming out of
these
and and sometimes ones higher
especially with the irrigation and we'll
talk we'll certainly show that in in
runoff so that's what nitrate leaching
looked like
now at the other plots
okay
the ones mostly with weeds in it the
scale of these are the same
we saw before i'm not scared sometimes
you can
you can i wouldn't say skew diff those
things but the scale of the the of the
data is the same in these in these
curves so we can see
some of the worst ones
that we saw were similar to before was
this first year
peaking either
say the second
set of samples
time back to about the end of the
growing season if we were kind of
looking at periods of time
and we can see that crab grass and
crabgrass with turf grass in it
especially the crabgrass and turfgrass
one had losses similar to what we saw
with the ones with fertilizer fertilized
up these weren't fertilized at all uh
after after they were established
okay
so if we summarize the the kind of
losses in this
um and
okay if we look at that the the greatest
loss we saw very little ammonium loss
and this is typically we see in turf
studies that we don't see much ammonium
leaching even if you put ammonium-based
fertilizer gets converted to nitrate
pretty quickly the greatest loss was
with nitrate and a little bit of organic
nitrogen coming out
on an application basis uh the one that
we put on that had uh turf with
fertilizer it was equivalent to about
1.8 percent of the nitrogen it was
applied leach through that that system
um and it was the only one that was
significantly different than other
treatments was the broadleaf one it
started low it never really had anything
leaching out nothing was applied to it
and it didn't change over time and
actually these tend to stabilize over
time
so the the kind of take home message
tends to be
that a dense perennial system whether
it's with grasses or broadleaf weeds are
pretty good so this is phosphorus i mean
this is runoff and the total amount of
runoff that occurred on the over the two
year period
and again if we look at these numbers we
were seeing 400 millimeters with
leaching we're down to about a hundred
so only about a tenth of what came on as
precipitation
ran off these sites which is relatively
i would think is relatively low even
though it's very sloppy area
these are relatively low
we can see that areas with turf grass
with fertilization tend to get the
amount of runoffs less than some of the
other treatments especially if we
compare it to crabgrass which was the
worst
but when we put even though we put
fertilizer and pesticides when we
irrigated that we see the amount of
runoff jumped up pretty significantly
and the reason that occurs it wasn't the
irrigation itself creating runoff but it
keeps soil and seed moisture content
higher and then any precipitation can
more likely run off and so there has to
be a caution i think
in areas with irrigation
you run the risk of keeping soils more
likely to be
produced runoff so that's just the
volume of runoff that occurred
so how about the amount of in this case
phosphorus
in the runoff as well as nitrogen and
ammonia there was a little bit of
ammonia not related to to treatment
there was some nitrate again hardly
relationship to to the treatment but
there was slightly higher amounts of
phosphorus in that runoff but relatively
small on the amount that was actually
applied so we could see going from turf
itself with fertilizer with pesticides
for some reason with pesticides saw
slightly higher amounts of of nitrogen
running off
and
with irrigation we didn't see we
saw slightly less than what we saw there
but
but again the the amounts are are
relatively small and that all landscapes
lose some and this is what
has always been my pet peeves people say
well let's just let's just let it go is
it going to be better for the
environment there's always some loss out
of these systems they're not 100 percent
at retaining retaining nutrients
so mark concluded from this regardless
of the plant type low plant density and
high in the seed moisture content
gave were the greatest factors affecting
runoff volumes
and so the need to maintain a dense
canopy
is very important perennial canopy is
very important an annual one you could
have crabgrass being very dense in
august and once the first frost comes in
in in september october november
whenever that might be you start losing
plant density and those areas become uh
quite leaky and likely to show problems
and he also concluded that the ammonium
and phosphorus losses in runoff were low
but increased with time they were they
were occurring their relative amounts
were relatively low
in overall nutrient loading runoff and
leachate were less than two percent of
the nnp that were applied
because i've seen laws written around
the fact that we see 25 percent loss of
fertilizer applied to turf areas
massachusetts is a very prominent one
likes to write land use laws around that
where there's no data to ever back it up
which again as a scientist you tend to
get
you get a little upset when you're
making laws that aren't based on facts
okay so the second one of the ecosystem
service stuff i want to talk about is
soil phosphorus and phosphorus runoff
and you might say what the heck does
this have to do with
with ecosystem functions well this was
done with doug saldat uh did his phd
he's currently an associate professor at
uh youth university of wisconsin in
madison and the department of soil
science went back to his home department
um so what's it have to do with
soil phosphorus and phosphorus runoff
from turf and an ecosystem service well
one of the things we
and actually i got grants to do this was
to look at turf grass sites as a
potential for
taking compost especially animal-based
compost
to remove
that from a farm that has excess
phosphorus because of importing all the
feed so they can reduce their surface
phosphorus water quality problems and
put on a large landscape like turf and
we also see there's a lot of interest in
using massive amount of yard waste
compost in turf and residential areas as
a way to to re you know get rid of those
as well as reuse those materials
so there could be if you can retain all
this phosphorus in that system that
might be a great ecosystem service you
don't then that this would not be a very
good system to do
so we looked at uh doug looked at first
taking some long-term
soil nutrient calibration sites we had
worked on putting phosphorus levels of
different amounts on and these were four
sites all across
new york going from the adirondacks to
long island that are fertilized at
typical fertilizer rates not something
that would not be typically done about
twice as much of what the soil test
would require but probably within more
traditional range
and so in these sites we had doug did
two things one he removed the soil
and removed the the turf that was on it
and looked at the runoff that occurred
from that so this is soil test level on
these individual plots
versus the amount of phosphorus in in
runoff the concentration and runoff and
so without turf there
you see a pretty uh pretty consistent
increase in as if you increase the soil
phosphorus level you're going to see a
corresponding increase in the amount of
phosphorus and runoff
and that's pretty typical of of kind of
typical kind of bare or
annual cropping systems where you can
see a pretty uh consistent and a very
useful tool then to to look at reducing
phosphorus levels to make sure you don't
have excess amount of phosphorus in the
soil but there there was this kind of
this relationship but what happens on
the same plot with actually turf on it
and the turf would be growing and see
what that impact would be
so in this case the exact same plots
with with with the dense turf grass on
them we see kind of no relationship
between soil level uh at least in the
range where we're raising phosphorus
levels
from typical applications and the amount
of phosphorus that's in that runoff
and so when you kind of look at this
where again the new york state law and
many other states they do a soil test
and if there's adequate amounts on don't
apply it well there's a pretty our
recommendations are down here at four
if you have four or more pounds of
available phosphorus per acre
that you
you have sufficient you wouldn't need to
put an application on but you can see
that could be significantly higher than
that
and not really see any major
environmental impact
now are there situations however
that we see soil levels get highly
elevated from phosphorus
and one of them is back to this question
of using compost on
turf and in landscapes and i want to
kind of expand it to the landscape ones
in turf areas we quite often if we're
going to apply a compost as a soil
amendment we're going to put a fair
amount on a quarter or a half inch
material in this case we did it with a
dairy compost
and and you and i'll show slide that you
work it in and that's on established
turf so this is a typical kind of rate
that's used to try to improve organic
matter in the soil
a better turf overall
but when we calculated how much
phosphorus that was at available
phosphorus that was actually putting on
a quarter inch was about 300 pounds per
acre of available phosphorus and double
that if you put a half inch on
we're again our typical fertilizer rates
that are about
a tenth of that so you might expect if
we're putting on these extremely high
loads of phosphorus
that you would have you could have a
potential for phosphorus runoff so this
is what the actual plots look like and
if we did the same kind of study
that we showed earlier that doug did in
this case with these are the ones we had
that we didn't put any compost on they
were down less than 50
pounds per acre
of
of available phosphorus
but once we start putting compost on you
can see we could elevate these levels up
to 500 pounds per acre and the amount of
phosphorus in the runoff significantly
went up and so there to me there is a
big concern about taking using
landscape areas
that
with high rates of compost applications
especially if there are are uh
are nutrient-rich ones which are
typically dairy or poultry other
animal-based ones
and so there are two issues with that
one that you can saturate the soils the
soil's ability to to retain phosphorus
and you increase that risk of phosphorus
run up pretty significantly
and the second part is there's another
kind of ecosystem effect that that is is
is going to be depressed is you're going
to suppress the carbon nitrogen
sequestration you would typically get an
area with less less organic matter and
so when we start loading up our
landscapes with
with compost two things could happen one
if there are nutrients in those compost
you could run the risk of a lot of
phosphorus runoff or you're certainly
going to reduce that site's ability to
sequester both carbon and nitrogen if
you have a tremendous amount of both
those matter of fact they'll probably be
losing those as that that compost
degrades and mineralizes you're going to
see carbon and nitrogen being released
out of that system you're not going to
really retain very much other than if
you have above ground
plant parts there
so the last part i want to cover on on
this ecosystem part is carbon carbon and
nitrogen's equation sequestration and i
worked with steve rossetti steve was a
phd student over natural resources i
happened to be on his committee because
he was doing turf work so i thought that
was kind of cool and now he's currently
an assistant professor at hofstra
uh i went to bu for a boston university
that'd be you
for a postdoc when he left here and then
he has a university position so what did
what did steve do well steve was working
in the the
baltimore
ecosystem study long-term ecosystem
study area and he took soil cores out of
residential areas and forested areas
there were 32 residential sites he
worked with and eight forested sites
again those forested sites were from the
baltimore ecosystem their long
term ecosystem research studies that
that they've been doing this site for a
number of years
and these the
ones coming from the residential areas
were primarily lawns with cool season
grasses in it and
there were a few you know trees and
shrubs in the area but but the primary
landscape feature where he was sampling
was from lawn areas
and so he took one meter deep
undisturbed cores broke them up into
four zones it looked at total
nitrogen and carbon
in those samples
and really by knowing the bulk density
then can relate back to
an amount on an area basis so what did
steve find well he found comparing
residential to forested that there was
more carbon stored in those soils in
both in residential and nitrogen than
forested areas
uh the amount of uh the carbon nitrogen
ratios were similar in those but the
absolute amount of carbon
in the residential soils lawn soils
compared to the forest areas on the same
soil series
were significantly higher
there's a time sequence in that
he had sites that were as young as five
years and the oldest one was about 45
years and he saw this kind of linear of
accumulation of carbon over time and
nitrogen over time in those residential
areas now it would have been nice if he
would have been able to go out another
40 years or so to see if this continues
but there definitely was over time and
a fair amount of sequestration of both
carbon and nitrogen in these residential
soils
the difference occurred primarily
primarily in the top 70 centimeters of
the soil we can see with carbon
the 10 to 70 centimeter zone this is
where the the major increase significant
increase occurred compared to the four
soils in nitrogen it's the top 70
centimeters even at the surface 10
centimeters that had higher in the
residential area than forested area
and
and the percent carbon uh was slightly
higher
again in the residential area than in
the forested area at at most depths
except for the deepest sample
and so we did a mass balance in these
areas and and
and and kind of adding that up um he was
able to conclude from this and i'll put
his his concluding statement up here
that these data suggest that soils in
residential areas on formal agricultural
land so these were suburbs that were
taken farms over had a significant
capacity to sequester nitrogen
and carbon following development in this
case for 40 they had data for 45 years
given the the large area of these soils
they are undoubtedly a significant
significant regional
carbon and nitrogen
balances as a form of sequestration
okay
perfect
final thoughts after 35 years
being here plus
this was my first seminar
36 years ago in december and bill that's
what i want to point out you see this
rose i had a rose tie on when i came in
the department i was in floriculture and
ornamental horticulture a lot of rose
guys so i think the reason i got this
job is i had this tie on build
geez
most people have not seen me without a
beard so this is pretty cool you know
and here you know those are two good
things
so those of you young faculty that want
to complain about startup costs this is
what you got back in 1979 i got a five
thousand dollar hatch grant with
inflation is now seventeen thousand
dollars
the dean said two years ago the average
startup uh
package for a faculty member in cals is
over eight hundred thousand dollars okay
so you young faculty think you have it
hard no technicians no post docs no grad
students a whopping five thousand
dollars a year and seventeen thousand
dollars in in today's funds so just to
just remind you people
okay uh when i first came we had
mainframes with punch cards there were
no pcs
smartphones we didn't even have i had a
party line phone with two other faculty
members and extension with a light on it
so
when that light was on somebody's
talking on the phone so a guy george
good who was a
nursery landscape person more than 50
extension i was 50 extension of bob
kozlowski it was 100 extension it put
three of us on the same line it was a it
was a fight every time that light went
off everybody was grabbing for their
phone so technology has changed over my
career
but i want to thank people
who i've worked with over the years my
first technician was ron white some of
you do know ron he was a phenomenal
engineer he was a turf guy but he was
probably the best engineer i knew
john gowan chris sancherico howard
piddick jeff barlow my current
technician back there
i left alexis
heinz off this list
she was a an asset for for a good asset
for a couple of years
then some of my previous colleagues norm
hummel was here on the faculty and and
joanne grutaderia who we still hire from
time to time
some more current ones and i don't have
a picture of jenny and
and kyle wicken but some of our people
such as frank and jennifer grant in the
middle here and field staff and other
ipm people
it's been kind of great
you know working with everybody
but the grad students are always the
best and
this is the list that i was able to work
with over
35 plus years they were good things so
there's a just grass hopefully maybe a
little more so with that thank you
new jersey is the most recent one
pennsylvania is right in the middle of i
don't know where they've passed theirs
new jersey
is called the most restrictive but
they're again they they all have that at
least for phosphorus have that similar
problem connecticut didn't do it there
were kind of two things in these laws
that were done
one did they exempt organic fertilizers
which
or or fertilizers that come from compost
that's one of the other kind of caveats
and it's like
excuse me
eventually that phosphorus or nitrogen
is going to be released out of those and
so it's it was mostly that's that's the
politics they're saying what we produce
especially municipally produced all
these compost what the heck we're going
to do what if we ban it because they all
would be banned under that under the
definition so so they decided okay maybe
there's not really that much used and it
may not be a big problem but that uh but
that but but new jersey i think their
law is pretty good but it does have they
all have a little bit of twist to it
unfortunately that's why i wish frank
were here actually frank has done some
of those studies
yeah his i mean his work and he was
looking mostly from a golf course
perspective which is probably the most
one of the most intense ones because of
mowing and and inputs and so there is
net accumulation you know so that even
though there is you do have to mow them
and you have fertilizer you have
irrigation all those all those you know
those carbon versions they do get the
the net accumulation is greater than
those inputs
so it's outweighed by those
and um and and it's it's an area i think
somebody should should do a lot more
work in um
but it it you know that when you had a
look at the bigger picture but but frank
had done a little bit of that work
well it's a great question because the
next study that was done we're just
finishing we're finishing up did that we
took well we kept the traditional high
input kentucky bluegrass version we
looked at low maintenance grasses tall
fescue and fine fescue with and without
clover in those and so that's the that
was like the and and or only maintained
organically with organic products so
that's the the next generation of these
things and and
the the take-home is after a while they
all perform very similarly the losses
are they they end up being low
uh because you you do have an
establishment
if you take that establishment period
out once you get a once you get density
with these things and actually
in some of the years because we have a
three years and i haven't seen the third
year but in some of the years actually
the low maintenance fine fescue with
clover was the worst
for for losses and i don't know whether
that's just an aberration or that if
that's real but if anything the the high
maintenance one was not worse than those
other landscapes but that's been the
other a lot of times you'll see
regulations kind of written around use
low maintenance grasses and it's not
always the maintenance that's that's the
issue it's you know it's the it's the
density and what it does
to the really the hydrology of the
system if it changes that it can
outweigh some of the potential negative
things and there is a period you get
nitrogen i mean turf is a good nitrogen
sink phosphorus it really depends what
the soil levels are initially and if you
put it on at a time when the soils are
wet you could get a lot of phosphorus
run off there i mean there's a
management component to that for sure
oh good
so that's probably it i don't think i'm
going to give another seminar dot
thank you
that is a more important one
thank you this has been a production of
cornell university on the web at
cornell.edu